man who knows all about the bill's mafia
he played over a decade for them
uh he's now at the espn and accn
and uh he's a a 10-year veteran and a
two-time walter payton man of the year
award nominee from the buffalo bills
eric wood how are you sir
i'm doing great how you doing rick i am
doing fine um what does this mean
to western new york to see all of this
go down right now
eric oh my gosh it's a long time coming
and
there is feelings in buffalo of
man we've waited so long to host playoff
games and then it's the year of coped
and i can't even get in the stadium but
they did allow 6 700 fans
in the building last week and they will
again this week but
you know it's a fan base that has stood
by the team
through a 17-year play after all which i
played
most of and they were just so loyal and
they deserve
every bit of this success that the bills
are having now so i mean
you got there what year did you exactly
get there eric you got there in
2009 2009 and that was my god that was
the dick geron perry fuel
um season then chant galley doug marone
we know what happened with him
sending a text did you get a text from
him saying i'm out is that
is that the way that went down back in
the day i didn't even i didn't even get
the text
and to your point here i would venture
to say that
it may be a record that in my nine year
career i played for seven head coaches
if you count the two interims
that's got to be a record that certainly
does so then mcdermott comes in
how has he changed everything eric
you know sean mcdermott he comes in and
he's talking about the process the
process and
you know he's got some philadelphia ties
and there were some joel embiid jokes
with him but
you know for him it was this isn't a
this isn't a one-day fix this isn't
probably a
one-year fix this is continually doing
the right things over and over and over
establishing some continuity within the
organization which we hadn't had in so
long i mentioned
all of the coaches turned over and what
they've done is just taking
a very strategic approach to hey we're
going to draft well
we're going to retain our own we're
going to get free agents that
john mcdermott brandon being called fit
their dna
they're going to bring in the right
types of guys and it's really paid off
for them and i'll tell you what
in 2017 we were ready to kill sean he
walks in the door
and in training camp they traded away
sammy watkins they traded away ronald
darby
they traded away marcel darius were like
coach are we
tanking like is this is this real like
are we tanking right now he said no no
no you got to trust me
and me and kyle williams and lashawn
mccoy and richie incognito we still had
some talent on the team we said
you better get rid of all of us if you
think we're tanking
and then of all the pretty talented
teams i played on in buffalo when we
go try and win that free agent lottery
every year and we paid
mario williams and all these big name
guys to come into buffalo
that was the year 2017 was the year that
we broke the playoff drought
you know it's fascinating eric because
the kansa eric wood uh former buffalo
bill uh pro bowl
uh lineman here on the rich eisen show
now with espn and more
and his own podcast as well um it's
interesting because the whole concept of
tanking you saw what happened in game
256 and the eagles were uh accused of
tanking
for a better draft position from nine to
six by not winning that final game in
front of the whole country
you know the jets um i was sitting here
as a jet fan full disclosure
saying that they should have lost every
last game because trevor lawrence meant
that much and
obviously as you know the players could
care less about it but
you went to the coach along with some
others and said hey
are we tanking when he first arrived
that happened in buffalo with sean
mcdermott
yeah we had it was actually a leadership
council meeting and sean
called the meeting to kind of tell us
that hey we're there's gonna be some
news coming out today we're gonna
we're gonna unload a few guys and these
were
our last two former first round draft
picks and then
one year we didn't have a first round
draft pick because we had traded it for
sammy the year before
and we took ronald darby in the second
round that was our highest traffic
so these were our three top draft picks
from the previous three drafts which was
the doug whaley
buddy nick's regime he traded away all
three of them
in training camp and then josh allen
arrives
uh what was he like when he first showed
up
eric yeah so josh allen came in as i was
leaving i had a surprise career ending
neck injury after the 2017 season but i
actually got to meet him down at the
masters
so ryan fitzpatrick and i are close
friends
josh allen was with the caa crew down at
the masters i was hanging out with those
guys
and i was still really close with
brandon bean and those guys in buffalo
and i had told them i said you know what
i'm coming to grips with my career
ending and all that
but i said if you guys draft josh allen
i'll be jealous because that's the type
of guy
that won if anybody spends any time
around josh he's just a guy's guy
he's extremely humble but he's also
confident he's got he's got that
infectious personality about him and i
said you know
that's the type of guy that i would love
to kind of pour into towards the end of
his career had that center quarterback
relationship
to where you know i move on to my kids
one day are like oh yeah there's daddy's
buddy josh look at him he's
one of the best quarterbacks in the nfl
like i i wanted that i wanted to kind of
mentor that
had that be my legacy god had different
plans for me and that's all well and
good
but when josh allen went to the bills i
was extremely excited for the
organization
just from a standpoint of i knew that
they'd have a great representative
of the city now did i envision him
in year three of being an
mvp caliber quarterback probably not
maybe not this soon
but the work that he's put in to
progress from year one
bill stink in 2018 is the worst
completion percentage in the league
2019 they improve make the playoffs
and he still got the worst completion
percentage in the league
and then in year three they go 13-3
they're hosting their second playoff
game this weekend and he's got the
fourth highest completion percentage in
the league
that's hard work that's continuity with
an offensive coordinator there's a lot
that goes into that
but i'm extremely proud of the young man
eric wood here on the rich eisen show
pro bowl center once uh
upon a time with the bills now with the
espn and more you mentioned
uh alan and interestingly enough just in
terms of chronology just in terms of
dates and times and things of that
nature
he is the first uh 2018 quarterback
to get a playoff win uh obviously lamar
jackson and baker followed the next day
finally even though um lamar had
chances before you're uh a university of
louisville guy as well so i'm sure you
were
intimately knowledgeable of lamar's
career there and seeing what he's become
as well what challenge does lamar now
present to the buffalo bills
to um keep this thing going for buffalo
what challenge does he represent to this
defense
eric yeah i mean lamar showed it last
week in the playoff game against
tennessee and he showed it throughout
his football career that he's one crease
away from taking it to the house he's
that special type of athlete
and he's got the ball in his hands on
every play and greg roman a former
offensive coordinator of mine in buffalo
who who's running the show on offense in
baltimore sure knows how to use them and
they
greg calls it window dressing there's so
much going on in front of your eyes
there's motions there's guys pulling
and it's it's simple concepts when
you're an offensive lineman or a running
back it's the kind of the same plays
over and over
but there's so much for a defense to
digest to see where the ball is going
and so that presents a ton of issues for
a defense now
buffalo played lamar jackson last year
lamar jackson was the unanimous mvp
last year and the only team to hold him
to under 200 yards of total offense
was the buffalo bills now knowing greg
roman they can't roll out the same game
plan they did last year
or greg will expose it that's the way he
is you know he's one of the
best offensive minds in football so when
you look at it the bills are going to
have to you know continue to do what
they did well last year and probably add
maybe a few new pressures a few new
looks to the table
to be able to have that same type of
effect on the mars they did last year
well in terms of run games you can't
compare the two i mean both quarterbacks
clearly can
uh can be a threat running uh lamar
um you know and you could say josh allen
is sneaky good when you
throw the mar in the mix otherwise he is
a dynamite running quarterback of his
own right but
lamar is in a in a different class by
himself right there
but my concern is for the bills coming
into the seas
into the postseason i mentioned and i
got some blow back from bill's mafia as
as as their want
that i was i was concerned that the
bill's run game was not going to be good
enough
in two crucial playoff scenarios one
being
you go against a quarterback say like
mahomes
and need to keep his touches limited to
keep his
reps and um and and to keep him
nailed to the bench by controlling the
clock
or if you need to uh
balance your offense in the playoffs and
and run
or if you will run the clock out in a
way and now zach moss gets carted off
how concerned
are you about the bill's run game for
the divisional
playoff and if they're so fortunate
later on
yeah there's obvious concerns there with
the run game and one of the things that
concerns me with the run game in buffalo
and the lack of it this season
was that when you play playoff games in
orchard park
you know there's a chance of snow
saturday night i know what a chance of
snow in western new york means
there's a chance of lake effect snow and
then what are you going to do if you
don't have
your ground game and you're going
against baltimore who's got the number
one
rush offense in the league so um you
know zach moss being out the rookie out
of utah
he's their thumper back they have devin
singletary who
had a really good rookie season last
year and he's been effective in spots
this year
he's over four yards of carry on the
season but last year he was super
effective
when he got touches over five yards of
carry so you know
they need production out of devon
singletary when they
when they give him the football but make
no bones about it this is a passing
based offense
buffalo ran four watts the buffalo bills
i never thought i'd say the day
the buffalo bill led the league in four
wide receiver formations this year and
the amount of times they did it
and so that's what they want to do and
they have a ton of confidence in josh
allen
and cole beasley and john brown and
gabriel davis
and the one guy that i honestly think
you can you can thank the baltimore
ravens for their 2019 performance
against the bills
for them going out and getting the last
guy mentioned and that's the bond digs
what do you mean last year against the
bills
the ravens basically said we have two
guys that can cover john brown and cole
beasley and whoever else you're gonna
roll out there
we are going to play cover zero they ran
cover zero 16
times against the buffalo bills last
year defensive coordinators in the nfl
if you do that
twice a game that's a lot they did it 16
times so
for the listeners at home that means
there's no
safety at all everybody's manned up
across the board you just blitz
everybody else and say
you can't make an accurate throw and you
can't you don't have a receiver that can
beat us in time
before that extra guy gets home now when
defensive coordinators do that they know
there's a risk because you can give up a
touchdown on
any play that you're on cover zero guy
misses a tackle on the outside
and it's literally a touchdown they did
it 16 times against the bills last year
and it worked they crushed josh allen he
only had 146 yards in the whole game he
got sacked five times he threw a pick he
had
a fumble as well i don't think they can
do that again this year
because of staphon diggs and i think
that
because of that game last year and
identifying that weakness they went out
and got a guy like stephon diggs how
about that so the team that's coming
into orchard park is a team that you
could basically say
convinced uh bean and the rest of the
grocery shoppers we gotta flip a one for
this kid
and he's been amazing i mean a
revelation totally
uh and beasley has opened up uh he he's
he's that uh
glue guy that third down guy that slot
guy that uh creates
uh so many problems certainly if you're
paying attention to diggs and
and i'm telling you man i mean just
seeing alan just stand back there i've
nicknamed him the mandalorian
quarterback he just stands there in his
armor and his helmet and he just
he surveys and then he'll just fire off
the rocket it really is amazing
what what the bills have turned into uh
before i let you go eric wood
your best bill's mafia story in your
time what do you got did have you ever
uh
uh hit a table have you ever jumped on a
table have you ever
have you ever seen anything that
personally give me your best bills mafia
story
and your time there eric wood give it to
me so last year
so so generally i do uh i'm the bill's
radio analyst along
so i'll do a call college game on
saturday then i go up to buffalo get to
have some fun
right on the weekends and call there so
on sunday i'll travel to buffalo or
wherever they're playing
and i call the game with john murphy
who's phenomenal they're playing by play
guy who i've known forever
well last year i got reached out to by
someone and they said hey will you do a
tailgate appearance before the game
and i said yeah but i'm not going to be
as fun as i would after the game you
know
i can't have a i can't have a beer with
you like i'm going to be sitting there
drinking coffee
yeah they said yeah yeah it's our
buddy's birthday we're coming in from
new york city we'll give you five grand
to show up here
and just hang with us that's fine this
is early in the season it's beautiful
weather i'm not going to be out there
freezing anyways
so i had a sport coat on and a white
dress shirt i was like now this is the
sport coat i'm going out to bill's mafia
into one of like
not uh this isn't a stadium lot either
this is like where the this is a grass
lot that like you pay to get in
uh day of the game this is like where
phil's mafia like
the guys you see on bar still hang out
okay so i go out there my families my
family's at the game we're gonna take
some pictures before the game on the
field and all that so i'm kind of
dressed up
this guy's drinking a guinness and i
must have said something that he thought
was funny
so he he spits into the top of this
solo cup of guinness and it just covers
me
so i'm covered in guinness beer now
before broadcast
yeah to try and pick up a few extra
bucks before a game
and then we all agreed that the only
proper repercussions
is that i should slam him through a
table and then i
kind of rocked so i rock bottom and
threw a table
and you know there's no way to avoid the
pictures and videos at first i'm like
hey camera phones down like
you know i'm i'm going to your
professional you know
and of course i got a few text messages
from the bills brass like
i know you're having fun and credit for
holding that coffee cup so people knew
you weren't drinking beers out there
but holy smokes eric we can't have you
slamming people through tables before
the game i'm like
i know i know it escalated really fast
so i didn't do any more of those last
year
well eric though but your defense is
like but we decided that's the only
proper punishment and it is
right right yeah no doubt yeah truth is
your defense that's what i'm saying
eric this has been fun let's do this
again thanks for the call appreciate it
absolutely hey bill's win we'll do it
again next week let's do it either
either way eric thanks for the uh the
very uh perspective that's eric wood of
the buffalo bills
formerly the buffalo bills now they're
broadcast espn and more hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here